hello hello my name is Adam Smith from
Nobel
yes many congratulations on the award
the Nobel box thank you very much
it must be it must be an amazing
environment I tell you and we are
nobody's prepared for that kind of I
must say it sounds quite calm around you
now yeah in the background it sounds
calm the background yeah because I've
been put in a home you know so nobody
can bother me going back to that
breakthrough in 1985 mm-hmm was there a
Eureka moment when you suddenly realized
how you could improve the the pulse
length so shortened the pulse length
became you know in different steps you
come in different steps and in fact he
can very very kind of naturally with
what I was doing so we wanted to amplify
there a very short pulses you know in
order to get more fit power okay because
you know power is energy divided by time
and so if you want to get lots per peak
power then you you try to get pulses
shorter and shorter and shorter okay
so trying to do that you know you so you
when you amplify your pulse you come to
a point where in you know battier oil is
breaking down on the laser yes so you
have to reduce the power but not change
the energy right I mean you have to
reduce the power without changing the
energy without changing well your total
energy of the pork okay because you want
to do that efficiently so I you know I
just can say well maybe we can stretch
the pause we stretch the pulse and I we
knew how to do that because we were
working on
Leon very short pulses and you knew how
to stretch pulses by using diffraction
gratings and so on so we stretch the
pause and of course immediately the peak
power decreased and and then we could
amplify the post much better much much
better and and then we we had to
compress it back so he came he came you
know by by step you know yes sir and
what do you give me an example of the
one of the most exciting things we can
do with these ultra-fast lasers well
what we can do is to instant accelerate
particles yeah we can accelerate the
particle with a really stunning
efficiency so instead of using
kilometers don't work zero it particles
right like it's you know we could use
systems with laser which will already
take only centimeters and you know
accelerators as a lot of applications
you know in the medical world okay
because they boat you want to create
Solferino for therapy okay there are t
you like try to maybe use radioisotopes
you know but every time one you want to
do that you have you know you have some
time to go outside
so this is all poisons are made you know
by reactors which are far away and so on
so it's difficult to bring them back at
the patient's bed but now if you really
make this actually a very compact you
can put that then in hospitals and
because they are compact you know you
can multiply them you know and you can
have one
there are fit all very possibly
described it's a most lovely example of
a such a successful interaction between
basic science and applied science the
whole
absolutely absolutely absolutely yeah
and and how utterly codependent they are
you cannot do it without the basic rules
yeah yeah and it's so exciting that
you've been awarded together with your
graduate student you know when I
proposed this idea to do an article and
she say well that's so simple you know
this is not a PhD I don't know of
another example where somebody's first
published scientific paper is leads
eventually to a Nobel Prize that's it so
it's a pretty high standard for other
graduate students to achieve yeah well
we will we be welcoming you to Stockholm
in December absolutely good thank you
bye-bye okay